bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est sens public votre
rendez-vous quotidien de débat de
chronique et de reportage sur Public
Sénat et c'est une édition spéciale que
nous vous proposons ce soir après ce
coup de tonner à l'Assemblée hier le
vote de la motion de rejet de la loi
immigration réunissant des députés de
tout bord allant de LFI au rassemblement
national c'est une crise politique pour
Emmanuel Macron et son gouvernement et
pour en sortir le président de la
République choisit la méthode douce et
la voie parlementaire pas de démission
du ministre de l'Intérieur pas de
dissolution encore moins d'usage du
référendum le texte sera examiné en
commission mixte paritaire et Gérald
armanin fait comme si c'était encore
possible de trouver une majorité ce
projet de loi il est très important pour
la protection des Français donc je je
propose qu'on fasse une petite pause
dans la politique politicienne qu'on ait
compris le sens profond de la mission
qui est la nôre la protection des
Français et encore une fois ces mesures
sont très importantes et je me battrai
jusqu'au dernier instants pour pouvoir
l'obtenir crise politique ou crise de
régime comment Emmanuel Macron peut-il
en sortir n'est-ce pas le moment de
redonner directement la parole au
français Gérald armanin est-il trop
fragilisé pour rester à son poste place
beauovau on répondra à toutes ces
questions d'abord avec nos experts
politologues sondeur J journaliste et
puis dans la seconde partie de notre
émission avec un débat d'invité 100 %
politique des
parlementaires représentant les parti
Renaissance LR Europe Écologie les vers
et rassemblement national mais d'abord
donc cette décision de passer par la
commission mixte paritaire les premières
réactions ici au Sénat avec Cécile
Sixou le gouvernement a tranché ce sera
une commission mixte paritaire après le
vote d'une motion de rejet hier à
l'Assemblée il avait le choix avec deux
autres scénarios l'abandon du projet ou
reprendre tel quel son examen au Sénat
nous estimons qu'il est fondamental de
mieux lutter contre l'immigration
clandestine de mieux intégrer ceux qui
ont vocation à rester sur notre sol le
gouvernement convoquera une commission
mixte paritaire au plus vite toujours
dans une démarche pour débattre et
chercher un compromis entre la majorité
et les oppositions un compromis une
conciliation à trouvé d'abord avec les
sénateurs LR car c'est leur texte celui
voté au Sénat que devront étudier les
SEP députés et les SEP sénateurs de la
Commission et pour le moment les LR du
Sénat ne sont pas disposés à revenir
dessus un mauvais compromis c'est une
mauvaise loi il y a déjà eu 29 lois sur
l'immigration nous nous avons voté une
bonne loi et nous n'avons aucune raison
de la modifier si ce n'est à la marge
rvé Marseille plus mesuré et favorable
au vote d'une loi immigration propose de
laisser décanter la commission mixte
paritaire si elle se tient dans
l'urgence ne dégagera selon lui aucune
majorité les députés Renaissance
s'opposeront forcément au texte des
sénateurs de droite si on se réunit sous
48 he 3 jours voire
4 il y a assez peu de chance pour qu'on
trouve une solution personne n'a de
majorité au sein de la commission mix
paritaire donc faut qu'on discute faut
qu'on discute faut qu'on cause
socialiste eux déplore le choix du
gouvernement de vouloir maintenir à tout
prix l'examen d'un texte si peu
consensuel moi j'aurais préféré pur Mo
simplement qu'on retire ce texte et
qu'il soit totalement réécrit et sur le
fond je ne sais pas à quoi va aboutir
cette CMP puisque
ou bien c'est le texte du Sénat qui qui
l'emporte et tout le monde se couche
derrière mais je crois pas que ce la
volonté du gouvernement manifestement
donc je suis très perplexe sur la
procédure qui a été utilisée et je pense
que le gouvernement est dans une impasse
totale on ne connaît pas encore la date
de la commission mixte paritaire en tout
cas la rencontre entre députés et
sénateurs s'annonce d'or déjà
compliqué quelle leçon peut-on tirer de
cette crise politique comment le
président République peut-il reprendre
la main on en débat avec Bruno cotrez
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes politologue
chercheur au CNRS et au sévipof Lucile
Schmith bonsoir et bienvenue vous êtes
vice-présidente du cercle de réflexion
la la fabrique écologique et auteur de
ce livre Emmanuel Macron a contretemps
publ aux éditions Bayard j'accueille
également Alexandre de vequot bonsoir
bienvenue rédacteur en chef au Figaro
enuplex également avec nous est-ce qu'il
est là oui jean-diel Lévi le directeur
délégué de Haris interactive bonsoir
Jeandel et bienvenue et laéticia crupa
éitoraliste politique bonsoir Laetitia
bienvenue question assez générale pour
démarrer il y a beaucoup de sous-thèmes
hein dans dans dans ce débat quelle
leçons vous tirez Bruno cot de de cette
motion de rejet je reviens à la à la
date d'hier avant de parler de la
commission mixte paritaire qui se
profile à l'horizon qui sort le plus
affaibli d'après vous moi je me suis
posé la question c'est pas si facile d'y
répondre non c'est pas facile
effectivement d' d'y répondre dans un
premier temps je dirais quand même le
ministre de l'intérieur parce qu'il a
beaucoup investi il a beaucoup
communiqué il le refait d'ailleurs à
nouveau sur l'idée qu'il se fait fort de
trouver un compromis euh de il n'a cessé
de dire qu'il débattrait jusqu'au bout
de la nuit que il il savait quel quels
arguments trouvent pour il va pas faire
le débat voilà mais finalement on a pas
faire le le le débat et c'est vrai que
c'est aussi pour lui un signe qui est
que son ancienne famille politique des
républicains je pense qu'il devait un
peu compter sur le fait que quand même
ça allait un peu compter le fait que sur
un thème comme l'immigration ils
allaient un peu se retrouver en tout cas
avir une certaine convergence d'intérêt
ben on voit que finalement ils ont donc
pour moi c'est un peu lui qui sort
principalement à affaibli et en toile le
fond un peu aussi l'exécutif dans son
ensemble et en particulier on voit que
la la première ministre à qui on a
confié la mission de trouver ses
majorités à géométrie variable on voit
qu'encore une fois ça ne marche pas
B répétit après les retraites je dis
c'est pas si facile de répondre à la
question parce que lucide Schmidt quand
on voit ces députés de tout bord de LFI
au rassemblement national en passant par
c'est peut-être ce qui est le plus
frappant les anciens grand partis de
gouvernement le Parti socialiste ou LR à
l'assemblée qui ont finalement refuser
le débat est-ce qu'il prennent aussi un
risque vis-àvis de leurs électeurs de
question de cohérence manque de
cohérence oui je suis d'accord avec
vous Bruno cotr a raison de dire que on
pense tout de suite à Darmanin et comme
il était candidat putatif à la
présidenti voilà donc mais je pense que
les la gauche en mêlant ses voix à celle
du rassemblement national après c'était
une motion de rejet qui était portée par
les
écologistes en prenant le risque disons
que le rassemblement national vote sa
motion de rejet parce que c'était eux
qui étaient quand même à l'initiative de
la motion de rejet elle a peut-être
sous-estimé effectivement
l'effet de répulsion que ça peut créer
chez un certain nombre de personnes et
puis il y a une deuxième chose moi me
semble-t-il c'est que j'ai peur que le
texte qui sortira de la commission mixte
paritaire soit plus proche de la version
sénatoriale qui était beaucoup plus dure
que le texte gouvernemental que le texte
qui était proposé après la commission
des lois par Sacha Houlier qui est
représentant de l'aile gauche de la
macronie et en ce qui me concerne ayant
beaucoup de travaill sur les questions
migratoires je trouve extrêmement
dommage que ce soit sur un texte qui
concerne la vie de millions de personnes
euh qu'on prenne un risque que le texte
soit si dur plus dur que le texte qui
était proposé en négligeant finalement
les améliorations qui avaient été
portées en commission des lois sur la
rétention administrative des mineurs sur
la question de
l'irrégularisation sur la question euh
sur la question bien sûr de l'aide
médical Géral haranin mais moi je je ne
suis pas d'accord avec Gérald armanin je
pense que c'est lui qui a allumé la
mèche en en allant promettre à la droite
et en portant les idées de l'extrême
droite euh qu'il all les faire comme eux
et ensuite en laissant agir l'aelle
gauche de la macronie en disant au fond
je peux raconter ce que je veux à toute
personne sans qu'on voit l'incohérence
de ce que je raconte Alexandre vechot
l'immigration c'est pas le le le thème
sur lequel les Français attendent le
plus les les les les personnalités
politiques et le gouvernement ça arrive
souvent 8e 9e position des
préoccupations comment l'opinion peut
sortir d'une telle séquence d'après vous
est-ce que un petit côté chikaya
politique voyez ce que je veux dire
comment rente P quand même je je pardon
je sur le diagnosti je suis pas
forcément d'accord avec vous je pense
que la question de l'immigration est une
question centrale depuis très longtemps
et que c'est pas totalement un hasard si
la crise démocratique se cristallise sur
sur cette questionl qui par ailleurs a
une question avec la la laquelle
Emmanuel Macron est assez mal à l'aise
et et ce depuis son son premier mandat
euh je je pense qu'on est moins dans une
crise démocratique voir une crise de de
régime et je pense justement que d'une
certaine manière l'immigration est un
peu euh à la 5e République ce qui avait
été la guerre d'Algérie à la 4e
République et que et que du coup ça ça
se cristallise là-dessus avec cette
questionl malgré tout qui fait consensus
dans l'opinion il y a un grand consensus
pour dire qu'il faut moins d'immigration
qu'il faut contrôler les flux et on a
une classe politique qui n'arrive pas à
régler cette question alors qu'il y a un
consensus de quand one des sondages on
est à plus de 60 % dans la population
oui mais d'ailleurs le le l'article 3 le
fameux article 3 qui portait sur la
régularisation des euh des travailleurs
étrangers dans les métiers en tension il
y avait aussi une majorité Sion en croit
les sondages de Français qui étaient
plutôt favorable bref à l'Assemblée
nationale cet après-midi la la première
ministre ellisabeth borne elle a répondu
à à plusieurs questions elle était
vraiment sur sur le grille notamment une
question de Mathilde Panau la présidente
du groupe LFI je vous propose d'écouter
la réponse d'Élisabeth borne St virulant
madame la Présidente panneau hormis
quelques secondes de satisfaction à
l'Assemblée et quelques minutes
d'attention dans les médias qu'avez-vous
obtenu
finalement madame la Présidente par
votre attitude et celle de votre groupe
ceux qui sont pénalisés ce sont les
Français les Français qui soutiennent
très largement notre
texte les Français qui attendent que
nous prenions des mesures fortes pour
réduire l'immigration illégale et pour
mieux intégrer les personnes que nous
choisissons d'accueillir les Français
qui veulent que nous trouvions des
compromis pas des coups politiques à la
petite semaine mais vous que leur
proposez-vous vousose
que le blocage de nos institutions vous
ne le proposez qu'une union sacrée entre
la nup et l'extrême droite vousur
proposer que le chaos c'est
irresponsable c'est dangereux et avec le
ministre Gérald daranin et tout mon
gouvernement nous choisirons toujours le
chemin de l'action et de la
responsabilité au service des Français
je vous
remercie ceux qui agissent contre ceux
qui bloque si je résume en une phrase
Jean-Daniel Levis c'est la ligne de
défense du gouvernement est-ce qu'elle
est audible d'après vous dans l'opinion
cette ligne de défense elle est audible
dans le sens où d'une manière d'une
autre il y a pas de critique aujourd'hui
à l'égard de l'exécutif autour d'une
inaction ou du fait qu'il serait dans
une forme de de
contemplation là où le gouvernement est
peut-être un peu moins audible c'est
dans sa capacité à pouvoir emmener une
majorité il y a aujourd'hui des Français
qui sont plus que ce qu'on croit
attentifs à l'activité parlementaire
dans le casre des différents baromètres
que l'on mène il y a une perception et
une identification de ce que peut être
les grand débat au niveau du Parlement
mais une difficulté à pouvoir voir
exactement ce que peut être les lignes
de clivage ce que peut être les
proposition alternativ et que
probablement au cours des prochaines
heures ou des prochains jours ça ne sera
pas uniquement au gouvernement à montrer
en fait ce que peut être ses principales
orientations concernant l'immigration ou
la globalement entendu mais de manière
un peu plus précise ce qui peut être
indiqué soit de la part du rassemblement
national soit de la part des réplicains
soit de la part part également de la
gauche d'une manière générale avec le
sentiment queon a aujourd'hui plus une
opposition qui cherche de manière
systématique à faire bloc contre
l'action du gouvernement alors que
lorsqu'on interroge les électeurs ils
disent qu'ils veulent globalement qu'il
puisse avoir plus une forme de
contribution que d'opposition même
lorsqu'on interroge les électeurs de la
France insoumis d'un côté ou les
électeurs du rassemblement national de
l'autre donc c'est ce qu'on attend
effectivement ça va être intéressant de
voir dans dans quel axe les uns et les
autres se positionnent et quelle propos
i peuvent-ils faire la commission mixte
paritaire si vous êtes des
téléspectateurs assidus de Public Sénat
vous savez forcément ce que c'est mais
on va refaire un peu de pédagogie grâce
à Quentin calm qui est juste là bonsoir
Quentin bienvenue à vous bonsoir Thomas
comment ça va se passer c'est quoi une
commission mixte paritaire la commission
mixte paritaire la CMP composée de 14
membres titulaires se députés C sénateur
avec une répartition proportionnelle aux
équilibres politiques du du Sénat et de
l'assemblée national il y aura donc
trois députés Renaissance un député
MoDem un député LR un député RN un
député LFI en face représentant le Sénat
trois sénateurs LR un sénateur de
l'Union centriste deux sénateurs PS et
un sénateur Renaissance la majorité
présidentielle seule donc Thomas ne
pourra pas décider en CMP il faudra
forcément s'allier et sans doute sur la
ligne du Sénat de majorité de droite et
du centre c'est en tout cas l'hypothèse
qui tient l'corde ici à la Chambre haute
du par ement écouter le président de la
commission des lois François Nouel
buffet cétait ce matin nous avons
toujours dit au gouvernement depuis
toujours qu'il fallait qu'il s'appuie
sur le texte du Sénat donc nous n'avons
pas changé nous verrons quelles sont les
dispositions et les volontés de la part
de nos collègues de l'Assemblée
nationale nous sommes absolument
déterminé à défendre le texte du Sénat
toute la question Thomas est maintenant
de savoir ce que vont faire les
macronistes en CMP Sacha Houlier le
président renaissance de la commission
des lois de l'Assemblée nationale a déjà
alerté sur un texte trop à droite le
risque c'est que ce texte sorti de la
CMP ne puisse pas ensuite être voté par
les députés Renaissance et notamment
l'ile gauche qui représenterait 40 à 50
députés à l'Assemblée nationale il y a
donc là Thomas un risque d'impasse d'où
le message des centriste Hervy Marseille
leur chef de file au Sénat qui dit qu'il
faut négocier cela va prendre quelques
jours voire quelques semaines oui c'est
ce on l'a entendu tout à l'heure merci
beaucoup Quentin Bruno cotre je me
tourne vers vous
sur les les conséquen pense de ce qui
alors on va pas pouvoir dire ici ce qui
va se passer en commission mi paritaire
ça va négocier et ça va négocier sec on
verra Lucile Schmid si ça si ça fait
pencher de nouveau le texte à droite ou
pas mais mais il y a est-ce qu'il y a un
risque pour la majorité présidentielle
un risque d'implosion de la majorité
présidentielle autour de cette enè
version de la loi immigration oui ça
vient d'être dit d'une certaine manière
par sachliier effectivement qui rappelle
que si le texte finalement adopté en cmt
en CMP pardon était celui lui du Sénat
ou très fortement celui du Sénat bah lui
on voit très bien qu'il envoie un coup
de Semon ce qui est de dire bah là on
s'y retrouvera pas et au fond peut-être
que stratégiquement on pourrait voir
effectivement un jeu encore plus
compliqué que celui auquel on on voit
c'est une partie de l'il centriste ou
centre gauche de la majorité qui ne
serait pas prête à voter d'une certaine
manière pour forcer le gouvernement à
dégainer le 493 et à revenir la version
de départ voilà et à revenir peut-être
vers la version de donc on voit une
sorte de gigantesque partie d'échec euh
très intéressante à suivre mais alors
par contre du point de vue de la
lisibilité pour l'opinion là on voit
qu'on va avoir de gros soucis oui
effectivement est-ce qu'il y a une part
de dénis de réalité dans le le choix de
de cette commission mixte paritaire
alors ici on est très heureux évidemment
on a une chaîne parlementaire que ça
passe par le Parlement mais c'est ce que
je disais en titre c'est un peu la voix
douce qu'a choisi Emmanuel Macron Luc
schmidth comme si un peu comme si de
rien n'était quoi voilà le texte
continue sa route parlementaire ben je
crois que dans ce que disait
jean-dianiel leville quelque chose de
très intéressant c'est le fait que les
Français sont peut-être plus attentifs à
la vie parlementaire ou à la difficulté
à avoir une vie parlementaire qui est la
nôtre depuis qu'au fond on a une
majorité relative à l'Assemblée
nationale et que là il y a aussi une
sorte de Paris sur la possibilité d'une
vie parlementaire qui ne soit pas faite
seulement d'antagonisme de cris
d'orfrais d'insulte et de sentiment que
c'est un psychodrame permanent et que
c'est s'opposés qui compte et non pas de
trouver un compromis et au fond c'est
offrir peut-être une chance à cette vie
parlementaire en revanche paradoxalement
le Parlement a plus d'importance que
quand la majorité avait la majorité
exactement et vous avez tout à fait
raison et le seul la seule difficulté
essentielle moi j'ai regarder par
exemple ce que peut-être tout le monde
n'a pas fait les discours qui ont été
faits pour avant la motion de rejet et
CIT très intéressant d'écouter notamment
ce président donc de la commission des
lois ce jeune Sacha aoulier qui
présentait les choses en terme d'apport
par rapport aux migrants et donc s'il y
a une pression qui est mise sur l'aile
gauche appelonsla comme ça l'aile gauche
de la macronie parce qu'en tout cas elle
est beaucoup moins à droite très
nettement que que le Baris centre du
Sénat euh et bien dans ce cas-là
qu'est-ce qui peut se passer alors moi
je pense que c'est compliqué d'imaginer
qu'il puisse y avoir un clivage au sein
de la macronie alors qu'il y a une telle
pression qui est mise je rappelle que
yel boron Pivet hier a voté parce que
Gérald D'man lui a demandé de voter
parce que en général la Présidence de
l'Assemblée nationale ne vote pas parce
que il doit y avoir une position qui est
une position de neutralité donc il y a
quelque chose d'extrêmement tendu et
choisir entre le destin des migrants et
le fait de rester un macronien ou un
macroniste je sais pas comment on dit
fidèle ça risque d'être un dilemme
extrêmement fort pour l'aile gauche je
voulais quand même rappeler qu'Olivier
dus SOP a progressivement disparu au fur
et à mesure que ce projet de loi
devenait très à droite et que au fond on
a vu était là hein hier à matinon
pendant le dîner autour c'est vrai dans
les médias on l'a plus plus entendu on
l'a plus entendu et donc on a
l'impression que ce qu'on pourrait
appeler l'elle gauche la macronie se
réduit est réduite au silence a du mal à
prendre sa place ça peut être une
occasion pour elle de prendre sa place
dans cette CMP mais dans ce cas là ça
suppose que les sénateurs soient plutôt
du côté d'herv Marseille que du
président de la commission des lois ici
Alexandre de vequot vous vous dites que
une majorité de français veut un texte
qui ressemble plus à celui qui est sorti
finalement de des des débats ici au
Sénat c'està dire un texte dur qui a
gommé quasiment ce qui était learticle 3
sur la régularisation je fais partie de
ceux qui pensent que le Sénat a fait
beaucoup de concessions parce que malgré
toutta non parce qu'il y il y a ce point
d'achopement dans dans dans dans les
débats qui est la la question des des
des des métiers en tension et le Sénat
finalement accepte qu'il a une
régularisation pour les métiers en
tension qui sera contrôlé par le le
préfet ce sera plus un droit comme ce
que ce que ce que voulait la majorité
mais est que c'est pas un principe de
réalité Alexandre dev qui on vu le
nombre de secteurs qui ont qui qui
tournent grâce à ces étrangers qui qui
ont pas été régularisés c'est c'est là
où il y a une vraie question peut-être à
droite c'est-à-dire qu'il y a une droite
qui a toujours une dimension sociale et
qui pense que on peut être à droite
pe-être pour l'augmentation des salaires
et une autre qui qui qui qui pense que
finalement l'immigration et et l'armée
de réserve du du du patronat euh donc là
il y a y a il y a un vrai débat moi je
fais partie de de ceux qui pensent que
si les métiers sont pas attractifs il
faut les rendre attractif surtout quand
c'est des secteurs finalement où il il y
a moyen de de d'augmenter les salaires
donc ça c'est c'est c'est un autre débat
donc je sais plus du coup quel était
votre votre question mais en tout cas je
pense que l'opinion oui et pour en tout
cas qu'on si ce n'est qu'on arrête les
flux qu'on les limite drastiquement
alors peut-être que des sondages
ponctuels disent le contraire mais ce
qui est sûr c'est qu'il y a un parti qui
s'appelle le rassemblement national qui
prospère de sur cette question là depuis
depuis 40 ans et moi je crois que ça se
résoudra pas sur un coin de table que la
meilleure des solutions est
de en commission mixte parire entre des
partis que le le recours au peuple le
référendum ça fait très longtemps qu'on
n a pas eu depuis le ré rérendum de 2005
sur lesquels les parlementaires
s'étaient assis ça a exacerbé la crise
démocratique et pour sortir de ce qui
est une crise démocratique et qui va
au-delà de la question de l'immigration
je pense qu'il est temps d'en appeler
directement au peuple et de faire un
référendum alors là-dessus sur le
référendum moi je veux bien qu'on en
parle maintenant j'avais prévu que
l'évoquer un peu plus tard mais pu vous
lancer le thème moi je m'adapte je suis
là pour ça c'est mon boulot ici et ça
vous fait réagir l'un et l'autre je vous
propose tiens une réaction et je suis
sûr que vous allez tous me suivre en
régie c'est celle de la députée du Parti
communiste Elsa faussillon
elle évoque ce qui apparaît alors est-ce
que c'est une crise politique une crise
de régime une crise institutionnelle en
tout cas voilà ce qu'elle nous dit je
vous donne la parole il y a eu une
défaite hier pour le gouvernement et il
y a eu je crois un vote très clair par
l'Assemblée nationale qui a dit que
l'Assemblée nationale refusait l'examen
de ce texte et donc le gouvernement doit
en tirer les conclusions de ce vote
alors on sait qu'il est plus habitué à
faire des 493 qui a écouté l'Assemblée
nationale mais je je crois queil y a eu
un coup de semonce hier
et que ça suffit de fonctionner comme ça
en réalité ça suffit est-ce que vous
parlez tiens de crise de politique crise
de régime laéticia vous dites quoi vous
je pense que plus qu'une crise politique
c'est une crise de régime et le c'est
surtout une crise de la législature hein
c'est et la crise de la fin de règne
d'Emmanuel Macron comment va-t-il tenir
encore 3 ans et dans quel état va-t-il
laisser la France surtout ça l'enjeu
d'aujourd'hui c'est quand on voit ces
Français qui sont mis finalement hors du
jeu politique il me semble depuis toutes
ces semaines depuis la réforme des
retraites on ne les écoute plus on ne
les entend plus on ne sait plus ce
qu'ils pensent regardez même les
sondeurs sont sont perdus on ne sait
plus ici dire aux Français qui nous
regardent voilà où on est la majorité
d'entre vous c'est quand même
problématique donc là Emmanuel Macron le
sait hein c'est l'enjeu principal c'est
dans quel état va-t-il laisser la France
est-ce que la 5e République peut
continuer HM à exister après lui ouais
est-ce que le référendum peut être une
porte de sortie je commence avec vous
Bruno cotè sur ce débat immigration
revenons à notre débat immigration
problème c'est que pour le moment
l'outil constitutionnel s'y prête mal
puisqu'il contingente le domaine du
référendum
euh donc certains disent que en voilà
voilà en en tirant un peu
l'interprétation de l'article 11 voilà
mais on voit et d' faudra presque
réformer la Constitution pour pouvoirire
ensite r élargissant le champ euh du du
rérend mais audelà de cette question sur
les référendum le le problème est
toujours le même c'est quelle est la
question qui est qui est posée la
question qui est posé c'est une donnée
essentielle d' d'un référendum et l'idée
n'est certainement pas pour le chef de
l'État d'organiser un référendum qui
tourne à une sorte de coupure en deux de
la France avec un choix drastique
binaire sur une question éminemment
compliquée parce que c'est très
compliqué les sondages montrent que
c'est plus compliqué qu'on qu'on ne le
pense il a effectivement beaucoup de
gens qui disent il y a trop trop
d'immigration mais en même temps c'est
vrai que beaucoup disent oui mais ceux
qui sont là qui ont fait des efforts qui
cotisent qui payent leurs impôts ben
pourquoi ne pas les régulariser donc on
voit c'est éminemment
compliqué la question du référendum va
de toute façon prendre de l'importance
il a une demande de démocratie plus
direct c'est certain nous nous l'ONS N a
pas échappé je suis sûr que cont que
dans la presse dans le monde on va les
citer nos confrères du monde Emmanuel
Macron l'a dit il a donner rendez-vous
aux Français en janvier il dit qu'il y
aurait un nouveau rendez-vous avec la
nationou alors ça c'était avant
ah d'accord est-ce ça ça changera lu
voulais prendre la parole sur cette
question du référendum lié au thème de
l'immigration parce que effectivement on
manie voilà on manie on manie pas
n'importe quel thème en posant la
question B moi ce qui me frappe c'est
que depuis qu'on parle de cette loi
immigration on dit au fond c'est la fin
du en même temps parce que Gérald
daranin a fait à la fois le Sénat
l'Assemblée nationale avec des positions
contradictoires et là j'écoute brenau
qui vient de dire en même temps
l'immigration et moi je pense que
l'immigration c'est du en même temps en
fait donc ça ne se prête pas un
référendum c'est en même temps de
l'intégration en même temps du contrôle
de flux en même temps de l'attraction
d'étudiants étrangers prometteurs comme
le font les États-Unis qui organisent
leurs élites dans une dans une diversité
culturelle totale sur laquelle la France
a beaucoup de progrès à faire
c'est-à-dire qu'il faut apprendre à
sélectionner les étudiants étrangers qui
viennent chez nous à les garder à
construire ces élites pluriculturelles
dont on a besoin et donc il faut arrêter
de voir les choses aussi il faut arrêter
de vendre l'idée qu'on contrôle
complètement les frontières dans un
monde globalisé donc je pense que
l'immigration c'est du en même temps
donc ça se prête pas au référendum et la
deuxième chose c'est par rapport au
référendum comment est-ce qu'on prépare
des référendums on n'est pas la Suisse
c'est dire qu'on prépare par les
référendum avec un énorme dossier mais
là l'argument d'Alexandre V est pas faux
ça fait quand même ça va faire 20 ans
qu'on l' pas qu'on l'a pas utilisé moi
je pense qu'il il faut peut-être il faut
peut-être faire un référendum mais je
pense que le sujet migratoire ne s'y
prête pas parce que les Français
eux-mêmes ont une vision complexe de la
migration il y a jeananieli qui veut
prendre la parole je vous la donne tout
de suite mais je pense que vous voulez
répondre par que vous disiez utilisons
le référendum sur ce thème on on on se
demande quelle question poser moi je
pense que la crise démocratique qui
encore une fois va au-delà de la la
question de l'immigration même si la
question de l'immigration et au centre
c'est un sentiment de des Français
d'avoir perdu les manettes justement euh
et et donc la question pourrait être une
question constitutionnelle notamment les
hommes politiques ont perdu les manettes
sur la question de l'immigration parce
que l'Europe vous l'avez dit vous-même
euh dans un monde globalisé c'est
difficile d'avoir la maîtrise des
frontières et donc de faire en sorte que
constitutionnellement les la question de
l'immigration dépende des hommes des
hommes politiques c'est la position même
de de LR pour une fois ils étaient ils
étaient d'accord d'accord là-dessus et
donc la question pourrait très bien
porter là-dessus ensuite je pense que
dans le dans la Constitution française
c'est l'article 2 on dit que la la
souveraineté populaire s'exerce par la
voix de ses représentants ou par la voix
de la du référendum c'est mis au même
plan et le général de Gaulle a fait CIN
référendum en 10 ans c'est-à-dire un
tous les 2 ans c'est-à-dire que la la 5e
République c'est une république très
verticale où le président de la
République a beaucoup d'autorité mais il
y a une part d'horizontalité qui est
dans le le référendum donc si vous
voulez de ne jamais l'utiliser c'est
finalement une utilisation bancale de la
5e de la 5e République quand on a un
pouvoir présidentiel très vertical il
faut que le la légitimité du président
de la République soit directement
interrogée et donc consulter le jean-del
LVI est-ce qu'il y a une demande euh
dans l'opinion française de référendum
ou de de consultation plus importante il
y a une demande de référendum pas
uniquement sur la question migratoire
mais quasiment sur toutes les questions
sur lesquelles auxquelles les Français
peuvent être confrontés euh d'une
manière globale quand on les interroge
justement sur ce que peut être la
réforme des institutions ce à quoi ils
peuvent être collectivement attachés on
est face à des Français qui sont
quasiment sur la remise en cause en fait
du principe de pouvoir représentatif et
beaucoup plus en fait quasiment avec un
pouvoir impératif avec une démocratie
impérative avec l'idée de se dire qu'il
faut qu'il puisse avoir plus de
référendum plus de démocratie directe
plus de capacité de pouvoir révoquer les
élus plus de contrôle également des élus
que ce soit en terme de type de mandat
qu'ils peuvent exercer c'est-à-dire le
cumul des mandats aussi bien au niveau
géographique que dans le temps et tout
ce qu'on avait pu identifier au cours du
mouvement des gilets jaunes par exemple
en était pour partie l'illustration
c'est-à-dire avec des Français qui
disaient on a le sentiment que nous
sommes d'une manière ou d'une autre face
à une classe politique et j'aiittilis ce
terme-là c'est-à-dire que ça embrasse
tous ceux qui ont la prétention être
notre nos représentants qui ne nous
connaissent pas qui ne nous représentent
pas et qui ne nous écoutent pas et sur
lesquelles nous n'avons que très peu de
contrôle et effectivement Alexandre de
vechot en parlait tout à l'heure depuis
2005 la perception notamment de la part
évidemment de ceux qui étaient opposés
que on leur dit on vous a posé une
question et la réponse n'a pas été
entendue n'a pas été suivie des faits et
que dans ce contexte là on n'est pas
uniquement à une demande de référendum
mais également de contrôle plus assilu
de ce que peut être la parole engagée de
la part des responsables politique
Emmanuel Macron qui était à Toulouse
aujourd'hui il voulait ça ça rejoint ce
que vous disiez tout à l'heure avec ce
rendez-vous pour le mois de janvier une
annonce importante au français il
voulait s'inscrire dans le temps long le
président de la République était à
Toulouse pour faire des annonces dans le
cadre de du plan France 2030 donc c'est
plans évidemment de d'investissement et
d'innovation à à à long terme mais Bruno
cottres est-ce qu'il y a là une une
occasion à saisir alors on a déjà posé
la question plusieurs fois et on a déjà
dit ici que le Président de la
République avait tenté de faire preuve
d'innovation institutionnelle en créant
des rendez-vous différents que ce soit
le grand débat que ce soit les
conventions citoyennes ou
ou d'autres mais est-ce que c'est pas le
moment justement de voilà relancer une
5è République ou alors d'en créer une
nouvelle ce qui est certain c'est ce qui
est certain c'est que domine dans dans
dans l'opinion un sentiment à la fois de
confusion et
d'impasse tout le monde est dominant
dans l'opinion l'idée que pourquoi
autant de crise ouais euh pour pourquoi
autant de chaos euh voilà donc un
sentiment à la fois de de confusion de
difficulté à comprendre ce qui se passe
effectivement où est-ce qu'on en est des
différents dossiers un sentiment aussi
un peu d'impasse et là c'est renforcé
par voilà on a élu en 2017 pour la
première fois un très jeune président 39
ans sans mandat auparavant donc ça veut
dire aussi ça traduisait quelque chose
ça voulait quand même dire que le
sentiment d'impasse préexistait euh
dans je vient de rappel
c'estd un niveau absolument vertigineux
en France d'attitude négative sur
l'ensemble de ce que représente la
sphère de la politique perçu comme pas
empathique enfermé dans ses certitudes
enfermé dans son impossible
communication avec le reste de la le
reste de la population donc oui il y a
une crise qui vouloir pardon de vous
reposer la question et vous interrompre
mais pour si on essaie fait pas de la
psychologie de de de de bas étage mais
pourquoi vouloir inventer de nouveaux
outils institutionnels quand on a le
référendum vous voyez ce que je veux
dire parce certain nombre d'évolutions
très importantes ont lieu le référendum
est un outil de démocratie directe c'est
vrai mais il y a d'autres outils qui ont
qui qui commencec à exister que d'autres
démocraties utilisent que la France a
commencé à expérimenter qui sont dans
l'air du temps de l'horizontalité tout
ce qui est de l'ordre des conventions
citoyennes des juris délibératifs voilà
on voit que globalement tout ceci mis B
à bout traduit une très forte demande
que quelque chose se passe pour qu'il a
une intervention à la fois plus directe
du citoyen dans les processus de
consultation politique de décision
politique que les élus rendent compte
davantage et au-delà de rendre compte je
dirais moi dans quand j'enen j'en parle
j'utilise souvent une métaphore et je
pense à la série colold case oui vous
savez à la fin S mais très bonne série
mais à la fin qu'est-ce qu'ils font à la
série de C case ils remettent sur les
sur les étagères le carton qui qui vient
d'être
réglé pense que vous savez ce que c'est
col je m'adresse à nos téléspectateurs
c'est c'est des
crimes élucidé qui qui sont voilà remis
enfin qui sont élucidés just voilà mais
nous on est face à une avalanche de
mesures d'annonces don on ne sait plus
quand est-ce qu'un dossier a étit ouvert
quand est-ce qu'il va être ref quel
refermé combien avont-nous consacrer de
moyens public à tel dossier
consir est-ce que ass a été fait pas
assez on a été dans la mauaise dire
estument incable répondre àettele Lude
schi est-ce que cette 5e République je
reprends un peu ce que disait Alexandre
tout à l'heure est-ce que elle est
simplement essouffler à l'agonie est-ce
qu'il fautilà vraiment changer quoi je
pense qu'Alexandre de vequo a tout à
fait raison de parler du problème de la
verticalité le seul truc c'est que le
référendum tel qu'il est dans la 5è la
constitution de la 5e République il est
vertical et au fond tout à l'heureelle
est de moins en moin verticale de moins
en moins verticale et Jean-Daniel Levi a
évoqué les gilets jaunes don je rappelle
que la principale revendication était le
le référendum d'initiative citoyenne
c'estàd qu'il disait le référendum doit
être au fond une capacité d'initiative
qui viennent de la société elle-même je
rappelle aussi qu'Emmanuel Macron n eu
de cesse d'affaiblir les syndicats
d'affaiblir les associations et et donc
on a vu ce qui s'est passé au moment du
du de la question des retraites où au
fond non seulement la France était dans
la rue mais aussi les syndicats étaient
tous opposés à à à cela donc le sujet
c'est effectivement comment est-ce qu'on
change les choses moi j'aurais tendance
à dire que si Emmanuel Macron veut faire
une réforme institutionnelle ça ne
fonctionnera pas parce que de toute
toute façon il faut qu'il trouve une
majorité il faut qu'il s'entend avec
tous ceux qui aujourd'hui lui signalent
leur inimitié et donc le sujet c'est
plutôt comment est-ce qu'il pourrait
s'apercevoir que d'autres pensent dans
ce pays et qu'il n'y a pas que lui qui
soit en situation d'exercer une forme de
responsabilité politique allez on va
prendre un peu de temps dans ce débat
pour parler du ministre de l'intérieur
on l'a déjà évoqué rapidement en
ouverture Gérald armanin que va-t-il
devenir Litia qu'est-ce qui peut changer
alors ma réponse est toute simple rien
d'accord rien du tout ni à que va-t-il
devenir bah rien et queanger rien tout
va continuer exactement comme avant
Thomas voilà c'est très simple d'une
parce qu'Emmanuel Macron n'a personne
d'autre à mettre à sa place et que
finalement Gérald armanin bah il lui
sert quand même il est assez utile dans
le fonctionnement Macron pourquoi parce
que il reste la courie de transmission
avec son propre camp les républicains et
de deux aussi parce que Gérald d'manin
ne veut pas partir que ferait-il
retourner à tourcoin que ferait Géral
d'armanin donc voilà donc rien ne va
changer et d'ailleurs ce matin il l'a
montré Gérald d'Anin il a appliqué à la
lettre le mantra de son ancien mentor
rappelez-vous travailler plus pour
gagner plus 7h45 il était à maison
alfort dans le commissariat de police de
Maison Alfort il avait convient convi
évidemment toute la presse et il avait
un message regardez je suis ministre de
l'Intérieur il l'a dit aussi clairement
que cela et ma mission c'est de protéger
les Français h euh démission quand même
qui a été remise à Emmanuel Macron euh
le président l'a refusé c'est quoi c'est
de la mise en scène exactement c'est le
mot juste on peut dire aussi
communication de Chise ça c'est à votre
guise hein vous choisisez ce que vous
voulez mais c'est une très bonne
stratégie c'est-à-dire que quand le
bateau tangue il faut désigner un
coupable il faut que quelqu'un incarne
la faute politique pourquoi pour calmer
toutes les oppositions et le peuple
également et ce rôle de coupable Gérald
armanin l'a accepté il est allé au 20h
de TF1 hier soir dire c'est mon erreur
voilà il a parlé en son an et on peut
dire que ça a été plutôt efficace parce
que les oppositions finalement ont été
vidé de leur substance elles ne peuvent
plus elles non plus l'opportunité de
désigner à la vindicte populaire le
coupable émissaire d'Emmanuel Macron à
l'Assemblée cet après-midi était quand
même bien bien ciblé par les différents
présidents de groupe mais oui ça va
continuer mais lui geréral il est rem
dans son costume préféré celui de
premier flic de France qui est là pour
protéger les Français et ça aussi ça
sert à Emmanuel Macron c'est porteur
avec tout ce qu'on s'est dit là depuis
tout à l'heure protéger les Français
c'est porteur pour le président de
République d'ailleurs c'est intéressant
même dans la prise de parole d'éisabeth
borne de Mathilde Panau juste avant tous
les politiques de tous les camps depuis
hier soir se réclament des Français tous
se disent Marine Le Pen l'a dit on est
là pour vous protéger ils utilisent tous
les mêmes mots et pour une fois c'est
rare qu'on le dit sur ce plateau cette
surenchère fait du bien à la France
pourquoi parce que le spectacle
politique auquel assiste les Français
depuis la réforme des retraites on va
grossir un peu le trait h et bah ce ce
fait finalement sans les Français ce
sont eux les grands oubliés cette masse
silencieuse ils ne sont pas là donc
écoutez il est grand temps oui que l'on
revienne aux fondamentaux de de la
politique qui est là pour servir le
peuple effectivement et les
parlementaires sont là pour ça on peut
rappeler quelques quelques fondamentaux
de temps en temps ça fait pas de mal
jeandiel léi on zoome sur Gérald
armanin et sur sa popularité si vous le
voulez bien est-ce que c'est vraiment un
poids lourd si on le compare à Édouard
Philippe Marine Le Pen ou même un
Gabriel hatal tiens CIT déjà un poids
lourd dans l'absolu c'est un poids lourd
qui plusait qui a progressé au cours de
la période récente il est devenu le
deuxème ministre dans lesquels les
Français accordaient le plus leur
confiance avec une progression au cours
de la dernière période qui s'est
essentiellement effectuée de la part de
deux franches de population les
électeurs qui se déclarent proches du
rassemblement national d'un côté et ceux
qui se déclarent proches des
républicains de l'autre les différentes
positions qu'il a adopté récemment les
sorties qu'il a pu adopter sa présence à
tourpoint le positionnement qu'il a pu
avoir autour pour faire vite des
catégories populaires ont marqué assez
fortement après en relatif par rapport à
d'autres acteurs il est aujourd'hui
distancé si vous me permettez
l'expression par Gabriel hatal qui a
connu une progression extraordinairement
forte au cours de cette dernière période
et qui est une progression qu'on a
quasiment jamais vu de la part d'un
ministre et il est un niveau
sensiblement identique d'autres
personnalités à savoir Édouard Philippe
ou Marine Le Pen pour prendre les deux
celles que vous avez cité tout à l'heure
après c'est pas tout à fait dans le même
registre il est quand même identifié
comme étant aux responsabilités
actuellement il est quand même identifié
comme étant le ministre de l'Intérieur
il est quand même identifié comme étant
plutôt parmi les personnes qui font
partie du gouvernement de la droite du
gouvernement et que dans ce contexte-là
il est parvenu à pouvoir sécuriser une
partie de son assise d'un point de vue
d'opinion ce qui était pas forcément
gagné si vous me permettez là aussi
l'expression parce que on avait vu les
difficultés qu'avait rencontré géralde
Darmanin à son arrivée le débat qui
avait pu avoir sur la manière dont il
pittre amené à traiter un certain nombre
de femmes et que ces points-là n'ont pas
empêché la montée de géralde Darmanin
dans l'opinion notamment au cours de ces
TR qu derniers mois merci Jean alors
l'ti vous disit tout à l'heure que le le
macoupa en direct au 20H avait peut-être
vidé les arguments de ses opposants
c'est quand même moi je suis pas tout à
fait d'accord avec vous on on va prendre
un extrait de euh d'un d'une réaction
d'un député Europe Écologie les vers
pourquoi je vous propose les écologistes
parce que le groupe Europe Écologie Les
vert de l'assemblée réclame une
commission d'enquête sur les moyens
supposément mis en œuvre par le ministre
d'intérieur pour obtenir des voix sur sa
loi immigration on écoute sur ce thème
le député Vert donc Benjamin Luca
déposons une demande de commission
d'enquête un certain nombre de vos
confrères se sont fait l'écho de pratiqu
inacceptabl digne de vraies tentativ de
corruption qui ont été exercé sur des
collègues ont promet des casernes de
gendarmerie des postes de police on ne
peut pas faire de nos territoires et des
services publics des variables
d'ajustement politiard donc nous nous
demandons une commission d'enquête nous
demandons à la majorité d'autoriser une
commission d'enquête pour qu'on fasse la
lumière si ces faits sont avérés c'est
un scandale d'État c'est une tentative
de corruption c'est une remise en cause
de la séparation des pouvoirs et de
l'indépendance du Parlement et des
parlementaires c'est extrêmement grave
et Cyel Chatelin qui est la la
présidente du groupecologie ver à
l'Assemblée je la cite hein disait cet
après-midi elle parlait de méthode
crapuleuse du ministre de l'Intérieur
lucde schmi est-ce qu'il peut
durablement rester à son poste vous
voyez ce que je veux dire parce qu'il a
été soutenu par le Président de la
République cette loi immigration elle va
reprendre elle reprend son cours son sa
vie parlementaire mais celui qui est
censé être en première ligne pour le
négocier avec les uns et les autes c'est
Géral armanin dans un tel contexte c'est
compliqué quand même je pense que c'est
compliqué après c'est pas moi qui vais
le dire ici mais moi ce qui me frappe
c'est qu'il a été voir tout de suite
Emmanuel Macron pour lui proposer sa
démission je rappelle que dans nos
institutions puisqu'on parle des
institutions il aurait dû aller voir
Elisabeth bornne qui est la première
ministre alors j'ai un tout petit peu
enquêter sur cette question oui et c'est
juste une une question de d'entente
personnelle entre ellisabeth Bor et lui
il apparemment d'près ce qu'on m'a dit
hein selon mes sources il ne la
considère pas du tout donc il pas
institionnellement je en fait je je n'en
doute pas parce que ça s'est déjà vu
quand il a organisé son son meeting pour
montrer qu'il était présidentiable et
qu'elle s'est invité à ce meeting pour
sans être invité donc donc on on voit
bien qu'ils ne s'entendent pas mais
constitutionnellement c'est un sujet et
quand il est intervenu hier euh vous
savez au sur TF1 il a répété à plusieurs
reprises je suis un parlementaire et moi
ça m'a frappé je me suis dit c'est quand
même quelqu'un Géral armanin qui est
partout et ce que dit Benjamin Luca ne
m'étonne pas du tout que des promesses
comme ça é é été faites bon en ce qui me
concerne je pense que c'est pas ce qu'on
attend de quelqu'un qui a la tête du
ministère de l'intérieur après le sujet
si vous voulez c'est que sur ces
questions-là défendre les policiers dire
qu'on est actif montrer qu'on
augmente les expulsions voilà il y a
tout un travail ingras à faire sur
lequel Géral d'Anin ne ménage jamais sa
peine et je comprends pourquoi il est si
utile à Emmanuel Macron parce que si on
dit qu'il faut plus qu'il le soit qui va
le remplacer je crois que ça a été dit
tout à l'heure on sait pas très bien et
je pense que c'est un travail
particement inrat d'être ministre de
l'intérieur mais il est clair que Gérald
Darmanin a eu un problème de limite oui
Alexandre ve il y a quand même enfin si
son rôle dans les prochains jours dans
les prochaines semaines c'est de
continuer de discuter avec les LR Bono
cot disait tout à l'heure que bon voilà
ça pas été si facile je vais juste citer
ce que Eric cotti a dit alors c'est
peut-être le jeu de l'Assemblée
nationale mais quand même il a parlé du
mépris insupportable du ministre de
l'Intérieur oui il a même dit qu'il
préférait travailler avec et discuter
avecisabeth Bor donc je crois que dans
la méthode de d'Anan sa méthode a été un
échec moi je pense que Gérald daranan va
rester comme le dit laticiaoua il va
rien se passer mais par contre il est
s'il a été présidentiable un jour je
pense que il ne l'est plus je pense
depuis longtemps que Gérald une toute
petite info parce que je suis vraiment
renseigné et alors selon l'entourage de
Gérald amanin il ne veut pas aller à
l'Élysée lui-même hein oui pour
l'instant il soutient toujours
officiellement édard
Philippe vérité d'un jour verra bien bon
il a eu tout de même des des ambitions
moi je crois que c'est une fausse valeur
depuis le début parce que un ministre de
l'intérieur c'est aussi un Bilon c'est
pas seulement être un communicant hyper
actif et aujourd'hui le bilan de de de
daranin est juste apocalyptique on se
souviendra de lui pour le Stade de
France pour l'océan Viking
où les les les les les sans papiers se
retrouvent dans la la nature pour
l'expulsion de l'imam ikusen qui lui
aura pris 6 mois en réalité il essaie
parfois de cliver de se mettre au centre
Géral d'matin mais ça ça fonctionne pas
en terme de résultats concrets et là la
loi c'est encore un exemple de de
quelque chose qui a fait pit donc je
trouve que c'est c'est un peu s'il y
avait un défenseur de Gérald har ici il
ferait un autre bilan que le vôtre mais
ça c'est pas grave mediatiquement il est
peut-être fort il sait ce se mett il est
très utile effectivement pour Emmanuel
Macron pour pour montrer qu'il a une
aile droite mais pour l'instant c'est
que des coups de menton et en terme de
résultats concret c'est extrêmement
faible oui mais aussi il y a aussi un
autre point faible c'est que certes le
ministre de l'Intérieur évoque ses
assises
populaires il en fait même un peu ça
voilà son mantra pour dire au fond je
suis cette droite
sociale mais quand on regarde les
enquêtes d'opinion on voit que les
catégories populaires ne sont pas au
rendez-vous d'adhérer à en tout cas pour
le moment de ce qu'on dispose pour une
éventuelle candidature on voit il y a
beaucoup qui ont été faites au moment où
il avait fait cette fameuse rentrée
politique à à tourcoin de de mémorable
et on on voyait que les catégories
populaires bah pour le moment elle était
pas au rendez-vous donc c'est vrai que
s'il est très sont où les catégories
populaires elles sont plutôt du côté du
rassemblement national très clairement
et on voit que s'il est très utile
effectivement pour incarner la fonction
de min de l'Intérieur qui réussit bien
ce type de personnalité habituellement
qui arrive assez bien endosser le
costume de ministre de l'Intérieur qui a
effectivement un boulot plutôt ingrat
dans le dans le gouvernement
pour aller au stade au-dessus
c'est-à-dire vraiment créer un
engoumement dans l'ensemble de l'opinion
là on n est pas du tout pour le moment
et on a quand même l'un des poids lourds
de ce gouvernement vousêes pas tout à
fait d'accord avec jean-danielessu mais
je vous redonne pas la parole parceon a
plus le temps en terme de communication
on est d'accord mais en terme de
résultat bilan c'est très faible cas il
est maintenant fragilisé et donc le
gouvernement affaibli et cette question
de la de voilà comment continuer de
réformmer le pays avec un gouvernement
affaibli et une majorité aussi
fractionnée se pose pour Emmanuel Macron
merci à tous d'avoir participé à ce
premier débat Lucile Schmith je rappelle
le titre de votre livre Emmanuel Macron
à cont-etemps qui est publié aux
éditions Bayar